- Oh my God!
- Yeah.
- They, I mean...
("In Numbers" by Jaleel)
- Congrats, you're in fucking debt.
(laughing)
You need to be more Better
Homes and Garden, and less QVC.
Got it?
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome, you're
welcome, take care.
- [Passerby] Gary, love your mic show.
- Thank you so much,
man, I appreciate that.
How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- I have been following you for so long.
- Thank you, man.
- Since I was like 15 years old.
- Awesome.
- I appreciate it, thank you so much.
- My pleasure, man, enjoy your day.
Eight, six, seven, five, three oh...
My hotel room in 20 minutes.
Email Stephland and Tyler
and push it 15 minutes,
so we'll do it at 11:15.
I hope you guys, uh...
First of all, about to
go work out with Jordan
who's been building my muscles.
I'm gonna show you behind
the scenes interactions
on email, text, DM's, in daily vees
'cause I think it can show some color.
I keep saying 'watch what
I do, not what I say',
this is one of the ways that I can
extend the way that I help you watch me.
That little chat that DRock and I had is,
is the start of it.
♫ With gold stains on my shirt
♫ Gaze my eyes down on my fate
Great day here in Boise,
Idaho, about to give a speech,
super pumped about live library tomorrow,
just had two great client
calls at Vayner Media.
Life's fucking good.
Just now, that little phone thing.
That was the best fucking
shit you've ever done.
How many peeps?
- Uh, we've got about 400.
- Juliusdein, nice to meet
you, hey, how you doing?
- Hey, it's a real pleasure.
- Yeah, you too, man.
- Just who I was looking for.
- Sit down here, I'll take
you up in just a second.
- What's up, man, how are you?
- [Camera Man] Nice to meet you, man.
- Touch a card.
- Take it out, do not let me see.
- Okay.
- Show everyone the eight of spades.
- Wow.
- All the cards are different, by the way,
just so the camera sees that.
Alright, this is what we're gonna do.
So, Gary, you're a business
guy, obviously very smart,
into the hustle, into
paying attention, being fit.
- The smartest, yes.
- Yeah, you're the smartest.
So, here we go, watch,
do me a favor, alright?
Do not take you're eyes off that eight.
- Yes.
- Alright, here, push it in
for me, push it in, yeah?
Do not take your eyes
off that eight, okay?
Pay attention, alright?
I know you're all about paying attention.
- I can't even, like, I
saw it from the corner,
I'm like how that happens is ridiculous.
You guys that really know how to do it.
- Yeah.
- It's some different shit, bro.
Just touch a card,
doesn't, yeah, that one.
Okay, just doesn't
matter, we can all see it.
It's not one of those types of tricks.
Alright, so jack of clubs,
this is what we're gonna do.
I want you to just hold
your hands out for me.
Alright, this is what we're gonna do.
I'm gonna take the
jack, you guys see that?
Okay, I'm gonna put that jack
into your hand like this.
Okay, put your hand on top,
and this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna take the, I'm gonna
take the seven of hearts.
Alright, squeeze onto the
jack, watch the seven.
You guys all see that?
I'm gonna take the seven,
like this, here we go.
- I'm holding it so fucking hard.
- Hold on, let me just, uh...
(blowing out) Bam, now I've got the jack.
- I just can't, I can't.
- [Man] That's so crazy.
That is so great.
- Yeah, I know, I mean...
You have to understand,
I'm like holding it with my whole life.
My whole fucking life, I'm
holding it with my whole life.
- [Man] I mean, your hand, you were...
Oh, that was crazy.
- My man.
To the YouTube hustlers
that just watched that,
when did you realize social and content
was really changing your world?
What was like...
- At university.
I'm 23, at 21, that's when
I started making content,
I did it relentlessly.
- Where?
- Uh, I was in London.
- No, on what platform first?
- I started on YouTube,
didn't find much success,
went to Facebook, and on Facebook I found
pages that could share my videos.
- And you were hitting
them up, messaging them?
- Yeah, I hit up hundreds,
and then I got one main
page that hit me up,
that shared me, my page went from
like 100 likes to 7000 likes overnight.
- And that was it.
- Bam.
- The most important part,
he was bisdeving and hitting
up 100 people and saying
look at where to look
at, look what I'm doing,
finally somebody said yes...
- Yeah.
- And that's it.
- That's it.
- It's not serendipity,
you went out and took it.
- Yeah, and that give me the motivation.
Five months later, got
my first viral video,
that took me from about
10,000 to half a million
likes overnight, and then,
you know, all the way up now.
Now I just hit 12 million
followers yesterday, so sometimes.
- It's really amazing, man, congrats.
- Good seeing you.
- Alright, let's do this, yeah, let's go.
(applause)
Thank you.
DRock, are you filming this?
Where do you live?
Well, first of all...
- I live here, and there's a
spot right down the street...
- Listen, listen, listen, listen,
that's gonna happen now, I think.
It's so crazy, you're funny,
you're smart, you know me.
You know that now I'm getting,
like, now I'm blacked out
and want do destroy your face.
Let me do something, for real,
based on what you just said.
I want you to come to
Vayner Media for a day,
I'll pay for your flight
and the hotel, and during...
And, and during that day,
we'll play bubble hockey
and we'll see what's up.
(applause)
Alright, DRock, let's interview you.
- [DRock] Nope, let's not.
- Yeah, it's, I gotta figure it out.
Take your bag off, this
is how we're doing it.
You told me to be more vloggy, here we go.
- You're doing a really
good job, you were tight.
- It was really good today, right?
Yeah, by the way, I'll
only be interviewing DRock
after I feel like it was good.
It was a good one, guys,
we might have to put this
whole keynote on YouTube,
which I'm now trying to
do, actually, these days.
Facebook is where I'm
most of the keynotes.
Or are we doing the Gary
Vayner trip channel thing?
- [DRock] Yeah, Gary Vayner trip.
- Okay, so we'll be doing
some stuff, it's coming soon.
Alright guys, I'm gonna
give my official prediction
to Jack M's each week on Snapchat,
this is the official official, like,
bet money on it, Raiders...
Oh my god.
- Yeah.
- I mean, you've gotta,
that's gotta be a core
of this whole episode,
there's nothing more ridiculous that that.
Literally, like this wonderful,
kind moment at the airport.
("Ghost" by Jacob Lee)
That is unbelievably awesome.
- You've told me that you
sort of do that at games.
Like, you like, attack the individual.
- You got to see it in real life, yeah.
- Yeah, I was like 'oh my
god, he's actually, he doesn't
give a shit, he's gonna go right
in for the kill right now.'
- No no, no no, Josh,
you're confused, my friend,
I'm a winner, you root for winners, dick.
(laughter)
Be careful.
(laughing)
- [Man] They love you, you're the best.
- But seriously, I
appreciate you, thank you.
(laughing)
- First, let me give you
your power, that's yours.
Thank you very much.
How are you, I'm Gary.
- Gary, Al says to tell you hello.
- Hi, my pleasure.
(laughing)
♫ I said I'm DRock with the lyrics,
♫ I shoot everything walking,
♫ I'm all precision, bad decisions.
- Should I put it out there that if I,
if the Jets lose every
game, I'll shave my head?
Phil, should I shave my head
if the Jets lose every game?
That's what I should do.
- A million percent.
- Yeah, that's what I should do.
- Yeah, a million percent.
- Alright.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
♫ Pull the trigger